في وقت قفزت فيه نسبه التضخم في تونس الى
10.1% مع بدايه السنه الحاليه وفق معطيات
نشرها المعهد الوطني للاحصاء نسق استهلاك
العائلات التونسيه يرتفع بنسبه 20% خلال
شهر رمضان فيما اظهرت نتائج استبيان معهد
الاستهلاك في تونس عن تبذير سته وستين. من
الماكولات المطبوخه التي يتم اعدادها خلال
رمضان تبذير الخبز يستحوذ على نسبه 46%
حيث يتم تبديل 900 الف خبزه فيما قيمته
اكثر من 100 مليون دينار تونسي سنويا
الفواكه لثلاثين في المئه والحلويات
بالنسبه 20% واللحوم ب 19
والحليب ومشتقاته بثمانيه عشر % والخضار ب
14% والمشروبات ب 13.4% والبيض بخمسه.5
فيما تقدر قيمه الاغذيه المهدوره من قبل
الاسره التونسيه سنويا
مليون دينار تونسي ويقدر تقرير برنامج
الامم المتحده البيئي الخاص بعام 2021 ان
حجم اهدار الطعام في العالم وصل الى حوالي
931 مليون عام 2019 ويعني ذلك وفق التقرير
ان نحو 17% من الطعام الذي يتم انتاجه في
العالم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات